[Musique]
la loi doit protéger la foi tant que la
fois l'entente on n'entend pas dicter la
loi la laïcité dans notre pays est
menacé et notre adversaire je le dis
dans la sérénité mais avec autorité
oui ses listes un mois il faut lutter
avec la dernière énergie
c'est la détestation de la france qui
est en train de s'installer dans
certaines communautés et c'est là contre
qu'il faut se battre c'est toute
l'importance de l'éducation mais pour ça
il faut affirmer il faut ne pas ne pas
avoir honte du modèle qu'on donne à
aimer l macron je l'accuse de refuser le
combat contre l'islamisme qui n'est pas
une religion qui est une idéologie
politique qui s'appuie sur le
dévoilement d'une religion mais il faut
le combattre avec les moyens y compris
les moyens que nous donne la loi parce
qu'avec et de macron jamais on aurait eu
l'interdiction la burqa a été marquée
par des violences recel sans précédent
on vient de fêter entre guillemets
l'anniversaire disent les jeunes y avait
4000 presque 5000 personnes dans la rue
samedi encore de violence encore des
black blocs ont été arrêtés alors qu'on
les connaît et qui ces choses là aurait
pu se faire on and on ne peut pas
s'habituer à la violence dans une
société de démocratie parce que la
démocratie
quelque part c'est l'intermédiaire qui
nous empêche de nous affronter dans la
violence voilà pourquoi il est
inacceptable
le droit à manifester est absolue le
droit d'exprimer des avis différents et
absolue dans une démocratie il n'y a
aucun droit à la violence c'est lui qui
incarne depuis le début de son mandat un
président de division de fragmentation
des territoires dont tout est à
reconstruire le fond le rassemblement de
la famille le travail sur un éventuel
projet d'alternance en tout cas la
formation gaulliste elle a pas vocation
à être autre chose qu'une formation de
gouvernement nous sommes le parti du
travail de la récompense du travail pas
le parti de la finance incarné par
monsieur macron certainement pas le
parti de l'assistanat le parti qui
récompense ceux qui travaillent ou j
[Musique]